well instead of breaking our dependence
on China the coronavirus paradoxically
has increased it in many places dozens
of American seasoned states are using
Chinese drones manufactured by DJI
Chinese company to monitor citizens for
social distancing there's a massive
problem with this as congressman Matt
gates of Florida says he is pressuring
the just Department to investigate and
potentially halt the use of these drones
congressman gates joins us tonight
congressman thanks a lot for coming on
so why apart from the Civil Liberties
concerns which are important I would
argue but why are these drones dangerous
China is massively expanding a Trojan
horse spying operation in our country
and you're a local police department
maybe unknowingly helping them the
United States Army the Department of
Interior they banned their use of these
DJI drones citing vulnerability and
potential value for other countries the
Department of Homeland Security wrote a
scathing report that said that China
specifically goes after local law
enforcement they did so even before the
corona virus so that they can get key
information transmitted to the Chinese
government and then our own Department
of Homeland Security wrote that this is
precisely the type of information were
worried that China might sell to
terrorists so even before the corona
virus Tucker you had this company
reducing their prices for drones by 70%
they drove US manufacturers out of the
market and since coronavirus DJI is
openly bragging that they have just
donated these Trojan horse gifts to over
you know 22 states to over 40
municipalities and when I talked to
these municipalities in my own
investigation they say well it's no big
deal we just fly them around the parks
and tell people to disperse or we just
make sure folks are social distancing
but the information that's being
collected makes our nation more
vulnerable and I believe the Attorney
General under the existing authorities
he has under the cybersecurity laws
should immediately ground the entire
fleet of DJI drones used by US law
enforcement we should not be spied on by
our own government in giving the
information then to a foreign government
that's hostile man I hope
you stay up late every night until you
get that done I mean that's something
that could be done is you just described
it very quickly and that needs to be
done congressman thank you stroke of a
pen your vigilance on that amen